مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض هذه ابرز عناوين
في حرب اوكرانيا الجديده
دراسه حكوميه تحدد تعامل جيل ما بعد
الالفيه مع ثقافه السعوديه مقارنه
بالاجيال السابقه
ضمن مبادره الرياض الخضراء انطلاق رحله
تشجير 120 حيا
البدايه بحي العزيزيه
في رابعه ايضا
رابع تثق الرحله اليوميه للصيادي الاسماك
في عمان مهنه متوارثه 49,000
نبدا من تطورات لازمه الاوكرانيه حيث قصف
الجيش الروسي واوكرانيا باكثر من 120
الصاروخا ودوله صافرات الانذار في العاصمه
كيابو عده مدن اوكرانيه اخرى في مجرى
تفعيل الانذار الجوي داخل مقاطعه روسيه
على بعد 500 كلم من اوكرانيا وفي تفاصيل
اسقطت الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه جسما
مجهولا بالقرب من سنه توب على بعد 500 كلم
من الحدود الاوكرانيا وذلك بعد ثلاثه ايام
من هجوم بطائره مسيره استهدفت قاعده جويه
في المنطقه واشار حاكم الى ان التهديد على
سلامه السكان انتهى بعد الحادثه
من جهتي اكد الجيش الاوكراني تعرض مناطق
عده في البلاد لضربات صاروخيه روسيه واسعه
نطاق شملت العاصمه كييف بصواريخ كروز تطلق
من طائرات وسفن وافاد مسؤولون محليون في
خاركه وسومي وميكو لايف ودينو بيتروفسك
وليفا عن تعرض مدنهم لضربات صاروخيه روسيه
عنيفه وتسجيل عده انفجارات مع محاولات
الدفاعات الجويه للتصدي للصواريخ كما
اشارت التقارير الى ان الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه اسقطت خمسه صواريخ روسيه فوق
ميكو لايف والصاروخ اخر في سوني وذكرت
مصادر ان الموجه الجديده للضربات الروسيه
تسببت في اصابه ثلاثه اشخاص
وقطع التيار الكهربائي فيها بنسبه 40%
بنسبه 90% وقال القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه الثانيه
64 صاروخا صباحا اليوم
خطب ردت سيوه
النوويه مشيرا الى ان تطوير سلاح البحريه
سيضمن امن روسيا للسنوات القادمه شهد
بوتين عبر الفيديو رفع العلم الروسيه على
الطراد النووي سوف وسفينه الصواريخ
الصغيره
من موسكوت
حذيفه عادل اهلا بكم ابدا معك حذيفه كان
هناك من تطورات جديده في المشهد بعد
الاستهداف الكبير لكيفو لايضا مدن اخرى
اوكرانيا اليوم
نعم
قريه صغيره في ضواحي العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف هنا تماما سقط صاروخ روسي في هذا
المنزل او ما تبقى من المنزل او الذي كان
منزلا هنا الذي دمر هنا بشكل كامل كما
تشاهد في الصوره امامك عمال النظافه الان
يعملون على نظافه الطريق امام هذه المنازل
التي دمرت بشكل كبير جر هذا القص هذا هو
المنزل الذي كان يعيش فيه اربعه اشخاص
طبعا لسخريه القدر خالد هؤلاء الاشخاص هم
من النازحين من مدينه ماريوبل الذين
منهم طبعا الوضع سيكون امن ولكن طبعا
لاحقت به الصواريخ الروسيه حتى هنا حتى
الان لا احد يعلم من الجيران اذا كانوا
كانوا موجودين في المنزل العامله عمال
الانقاذ والدفاع
في رفع الانقاض والبحث عن ضحايا لم يجدوا
في هذا المنزل حتى الان اي ضحيه وهذا
المنزل الذي امامك الان في الشاشه هذا هو
المنزل الذي اصيب فيه ثلاثه اشخاص الجد
والابنه والحفيده ونقلوا الى المستشفى
لتلقي الرعايه الصحيه كما تتابع امامك
ايضا المنزل دمر بشكل كبير الان اا هنا
المواطنين يعني يتحدثون عن همم الاماكن
التي يمكن ان يلجا اليها او الاقارب الذين
يمكن ان يلجاوا اليهم خاصه ان درجات
الحراره منخفضه جدا والوضع همم طبعا صعب
جدا وانقطاع الكهرباء المستمر الوضع في
العاصمه 40% من المدينه هي خارج تغطيه
شبكه الكهرباء 64 صاروخا نحو الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المختلفه في اوديسا بروجه هكذا
في سومي وميكا لايف وحتى الغربه الاوكراني
في الفيف وكذلك في مدينه
الشريجه
اعلن- طبعا اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانيه عن
الدعم هؤلاء المواطنين او البحث او او
توفير سكن بديل له بايضا همم حتى تتم
صيانه هذه المنازل او استعاده منازل بهم
ما هي التداعيات ربما لهذه العمليات
العسكريه سواء في كيف او في
المناطق ربما المواجهات العسكريه على
الاوضاع في موسكو يعني ان كان هناك من
تداعيات في المواقف العسكريه والسياسيه
هيك
مرحبا خالد حقيقه اليوم كما تحدثت الدفاع
في بيانها كان هناك طبعا تكثيف نشط في
اربعه اتجاهات للقصف في جميع النواحي
اوكرانيا من بينها طبعا جنوب دونات
كمتحدثت الدفاع اليوم كان هناك تحديد نحو
30 مقاتل اوكراني همم في منطقه حركيه ايضا
تم القضاء على منظومه دفاع اوكرانيه
بالاضافه الى تدمير منظومه ايضا تابعه
للقوات الوكرانيات اذا هو كمان معتز همم
كل يوم من الدفاع همم هو الحديث يوم حديث
نفسه يجري عن العمليه العسكريه التي تجيها
روسيا في اوكرانيا لم يكن هناك اليوم
حقيقه همم اي همم زياده في تصريحات على
خلفيه القصف الذي شهدته اوكرانيا منذ صباح
اليوم لم يكن هناك تحديث او تبرير لهذا
القذف المكثف الذي همم
توجه الى اوكرانيا منذ صباح اليوم الحديث
اليوم كان قبل المعتاد وكان هناك ايضا
حديث عن همم عن همم تدمير مجموعه ايضا من
المقاتلين الاوكرانيين في جنوب دونيز كما
قالت ادي دفاع اليوم في البدايه بيانيها
خلل
هل من دلالات كانت يا اخيرا على ايه
توجهات جديده ربما في همم
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه الان في التعامل مع
معطيات الحرب سريعا
حقيقه خالد كمال
الرئيس الروسيه مع القاده العسكريين
واليوم كنا شهدنا الضم اربع سفن حربيه
جديده الى الاسطول البحري الروسي وكان قد
توعد الرئيس الروسي بانه سيزيد وزير العمل
وبناء السفن الحربيه كان اليوم على راسها
اطلاق الغواصه الحربيه الكسندر الثالث
عشر
صاروخان باريستيا عابرا للقارات الى روسيا
طبعا تزيد من تكثيف عمليه التسريح سواء
عليه قواتها او عمليه بناء السفن او حتى
همم
تصنيع الاسلحه على خلفيه طبعا الخبره التي
سبتها كما تحدث الرئيس الروسي من العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الرابعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل
جدا تستقبل سفينه جلاله الملك الدرعيه
ثاني سفلي مشروع السروات البحريه السعوديه
اهلا بكم من جديد وصلت سفينه جلاله الملك
الدرعيه الى جده غربيه السعوديه حيث
استقرت في قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بالاسطول الغربيه في جده تعده سفينه جلاله
الملك الدرعيه السفينه الثانيه ضمن مشروع
السروات الذي يضم 5 سفن قتاليه
وتعزيز الامن البحري في المنطقه وحمايه
المصالح الاستراتيجيه الحيويه
هذا اليوم المبارك وصول سفينه جلاله الملك
الدرعيه الى ارض الوطن وهذه السفينه تعتبر
سفينه الثانيه في مشروع السروات وهي احدث
سفينه القتاليه في فئاتها على مستوى
العالم مزوده بانظمه قتاليه متطوره جدا
وانظمه استشعار
بالاضافه الى نظام اداره المعركه السعوديه
الصبح
نشرته وزاره الثقافه السعوديه تقريرا
تضمنا نتائج دراسه تحليليه اجرتها على جيل
ما بعد الالفيه رمزت اليهم بالجيل زد
الكشف عن تفضيلاته للفعاليات والانشطه
الثقافيه في البلاد من ابرز نتائج هذه
الدراسه ان 78% من جيل ما بعد الالفيه في
السعوديه متحمسون للتجارب الثقافيه خصوصا
سكان المناطق الشماليه مشيرتان في الوقت
ذاته الى ان التكاليف المرتفع تعد اهم
المعوقات التي تحول دون حضورهم لهذه
الفعليه
تفاصيل اكتر حول ثقافه جيل ما بعد الالفيه
في السعوديه نستعرضها مع زميل سالم الراجح
الكثير من التساؤلات تدور حول الجيل
الجديد او جيل بعد الالفيه عن اهتماماتهم
وطرق تفكيرهم وعن مستقبلهم ايضا
ويمثل هذا الجيل نحو 99% من اجمالي عدد
سكان السعوديه وفقا لاخر البيانات الرسميه
وزاره الثقافه السعوديه نشرت دراسه حول
نظره جيل ما بعد الالفيه للانشطه
والفعاليات الثقافيه
78% من جيل ما بعد الالفيه في السعوديه
متحمسون للتجارب الثقافيه وخصوصا سكان
شمال البلاد وفقا للدراسه
التكاليف المرتفعه والاوقات غير المناسبه
اكبر العقبات التي تمنع جيل ما بعد
الالفيه من حضور الفعاليات الثقافيه التي
تنظم في مختلف مناطق السعوديه تعديل
المزاج والسعي نحو اشباع الشغف من اكثر
الدوافع التي تحدد مفهوم الهوايه لدى جيل
ما بعد الالفيه وكيف يقضون اوقاتهم
السينما ومشاهده الافلام اكثر الانشطه
الترفيهيه رواجن ورغبه دجيل ما بعد
الالفيه او ما يسمى بالجيل زد وهذا يجعل
الفرصه مواتيه لصناع الافلام ودور السينما
لاستغلال هذه الرغبه في صنع المزيد من
الاعمال
وتوصلت الدراسه التي اجرتها وزاره الثقافه
السعوديه الى زياده الوعي الى دجيل ما بعد
الالفيه لنعارض الكتب وفعاليات الفنون
البصريه مثل فعاليات نور الرياض
الصور افضل وسيله للتواصل مع جيل ما بعد
الالفيه حيث اظهرت الدراسه ان هذا الجيل
يفضل التواصل البصري والفعاليات في
الاماكن المفتوحه
في جامعه الملك سعود الدكتور عبد السلام
الوهيبي حياك الله الدكتور
اول شركه تقرا هذه النتائج الدراسه
من ناحيه حجم العينه على هذا الكبير 5,000
وشويه وغطت يعني اجيال مختلفه همم النتائج
يعني يمكن اكثر شيء لفتني في النتائج انه
في اختلاف ما بين الذكور والاناث في ما هو
المنشطه الثقافي من الذكور يركزون على
البعد الثقافه
والتراث يعني بينما في ال بالنسبه
للاناث هي اكثر شيء اسلوب حياه همم الطبخ
مثلا والازياء والحكاوي فهذا الفارق كان
ملفت الحقيقي
واضح انه
مثلا المتكرره انه في دائما اختلاف ما بين
الجنسين في كل مكان بالعالم في كل ثقافه
بالعالم في رؤيه الامور وانعكست او ان
وجدت فيها هذا المجال وبالنسبه لاقبال هذا
الجيل على المناشد الثقافيه يعني الكلام
عن
الفنون البصريه السينما وغيرها ايضا
الموسيقى فكيف شايفه ايضا بالنسبه لي بناء
على هذه الدراسات
الواقع عندنا هنا في نهايه الاقبال على
المناقشطه الثقافيه
والمقارنه المرجعيه اللي هي الدول الاخرى
همم في في المسرح ركز بالذات على قضيه
المسلحه والفنون البصريه
والموسيقيه والمتاح في يبدو انه هذه 100
خاصه بهذا الجيل يبدو انه هذه يعني خصيصه
ثقافيه وهنا وقت على ما
يكون في قبال على قضيه الذات المتاحف تقصد
انه ما في فرق بين هذه الاجيال في مساله
الاقبال على المتاهه بتحديدا هذا ما زعموه
المتاحف في مقابل اعداد الاخرين والجنسيات
الاخرى تحدث عن المتاحف في دول متقدمه على
سبيل المثال هذه موجوده صحيح
ما كان في خليجيه بشكل عام لكن مقابل
التجاريه في نفس المدينه تلقى تمثيل لهم
كبير في المتاحف
همم يجتذب مو بجوز من الممارسه بالمقابل
الاقبال على المهرجانات كبير والتقرير شاف
انه الاجيال الاقدام بالذات ال- ال-
اقدم واحد من هذا الستينات يحب المهرجانات
بشكل اكبر ههه ايضا
ايضا في همم نتيجه لففتتني الحقيقه
بالموضوع اللي هو انه الثلاثه اجياله اكس
واي زي كلهم يحبونه ثقافيه بس التقرير راى
ان الجيل ما بعد الالفيه الجيل الزد اكثر
نشاط من الاجيال الاخرى في الاقبال على
هذه النشاطات وفي المشاركه فيها كم
التطوعين
78 متحمسون للتجارب الثقافي من العينين
وخصوصا سكان شمال البلاد في دلائل هذا
الامر له سكان شمال البلاد تحديدا يخصهم
هذا التقرير من هذه النسبه بان لديهم حماس
بالفعل همم
يمكن
المنطقه الشماليه من المملكه عدد السكان
في مو كبير جدا
فبالتالي اي اختلاف
بالاجابات
تؤثر يعني ترفع الاجابه نعم ولا لا فهذه
لها دور كبير جدا بصراحه لم اطلع على حجم
العينه في قضيه شمال لكن اعرف من خبره من
خلال العمل في مركز الوطني العام انه لما
تكون المنطقه همم مليانه بالسكان اي نتيجه
تكون حساسه التكاليف المرتفع الاوقات غير
المناسبه هي اكثر العقبات التي تمنعها
هؤلاء عن حضور الفعاليات الثقافيه في
مختلف المناطق هل تتفق مع هذا هذه النتيجه
بانه هي الاسباب الرئيسيه
عامه يعني موجوده بشكل عام عند همم جنس
الثلاثه ولا يبعد منطقه معينه في همم
الحاحه او تكرار من مختلف الفئات على ان
ال ال السعر وعلى ان التوقيت هذول اكبر
عائقين ويمكن انه كذلك الفعاليات ما هي
موجوده في كل المناطق المملكه
على مناطق المملكه بشكل متساوي مثلا او او
متساوي لكن انها مركزه في مناطق اكثر من
غيرها طيب
من الارقام حول استخدامات جيل ما بعد دلال
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ايضا مع الزمان
منذ ما يزيد عن 12 عاما بدات وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي رحلتها في هذا العالم
واصبحت الادوات الاساسيه التي تحدد يوم
الانسان كيف يقضيه وعلى اي منصه الواتساب
اكثر التطبيقات شيوعا واستخداما لدجيل ما
بعد الالفيه بسبعه وثمانون في المئه يليه
سناب شات بنسبه ثمانيه وسبعين في المئه في
مجال تطبيق ثالثا كما نشاهد في هذا رسم
البياني باربعه 74% وفقا للدراسه التي
اجرتها وزاره الثقافه السعوديه ما هي
استخدامات جيل ما بعد الالفيه لوسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي
الحصول على المعلومات وشراء السلع اضافه
الى الخدمات وتحميل البرامج والالعاب ابرز
الاستخدامات التي ينفذها جيل ما بعد
الالفيه عبر وسائل التواصل
ويقضي هذا الجيل سبع ساعات يوميا كمعدل
متوسط لممارسه الانشطه عبر الانترنت منها
خمس ساعات لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
واتساب وسناب شات والانستغرام اهم ثلاث
وسائل لاستهداف جيل ما بعد الالفيه
بالاعلانات بشرط ان تكون جذابه ومبتكره
شايف شلون الزمن تغيرت دكتور عبد السلام
زمان كانت الكتب
المخطوطات وغيرها من الامور الموسيقى
شرائطه لتشكل ثقافه الانسان اليوم اصبحت
واتساب 78 او 87% سناب 78% تكتب
74% سبع ساعات يقضيها يعني على على الهاتف
او على الموبايل ايضا كيف شايف هذا
الموضوع كيف
همم
هنا حول قضيه الجيل الجديد واستخدام وسائل
التواصل
من عملي بالجامعه ارى تغير سريع ايجابي في
قضيه الحصول على المعلومات لكن ايش
المشكله فيها ايضا هذا انه سبع ثمان ساعات
مع جهاز معنا عزله عن العالم الحقيقي
عند الاجيال بشكل همم حتى صارت حتى عند
الكبار
قضيه بس يعني انه قارب كمان تشوفهم
الانسان بالتفاعل الحقيقي مع البشر يعني
الحديث وجه الوجه تعبيرات الوجه همم
مشاركه الحكايات همم اذا اذا الاجيال
الجديده بتحصل المعلومه بسرعه وذكيه
غير المعلومات
اذا سبع ساعات ثمان ساعات مع جهاز طيب متى
جاء متى الساعات اللي فيها تفاعل مع
الاخرين يعني اذا الواحد مثلا عمره
بالعشرينات سبع ساعات ثمان ساعات اذا جاء
عمره بالسبعين ما هي ذكريات العمر يعني
وين قضيه وقتك مع الاصدقاء او طلعت رحلات
الاشياء هذه لكن
ربما هناك اسئله كذلك اكثر اهميه منهم
هؤلاء كيف يفكرون همم كيف تشكلت ايضا
ثقافتهم كيف راح يكون دورهم مستقبلا في
التعامل مع الاحداث مع البلاد مع
الاحتياجات مع الاهداف مع الخطط مع
التنميه مع غيرها من الامور
لما لما اتكلم مع الشباب اللي هم الان في
الجامعه يدرس في الجامعه طول عمره 20 19
21 22
اقرب في قيم العمل
لاجدادكم
للاباء اللي في عمري مننا احنا يعني يعني
الاجيال هذه ريستورنج استعاده قيام العمل
اللي يمكن انها انخفضت عند همم جيل الطفره
بالتالي من ناحيه قيم العمل نرى انه في
تحسن كبير
على الشركات الاعمال
يصنعون الماء في الكافيات في المشاريع
بالتاكيد هذا نشوف احنا بكثره وفي كل
مناطق المملكه احص
ائيه البطاله الرقم الادنى الاطلاق 44%
سلبيه
يعني
السلبيه اللي انا خايف فيها تجربه الحياه
بس سبع ساعات ثمان ساعات مع جهاز
تجربه جديده على البشر كلهم يعني ما نعرف
بعدين ايش يصير يعني مو الكاريكاتير اللي
مطلع هم كانت اول تمنع ولدها لا يروح
للشارع يلعب الان تسحب الولد بالقوه الى
الشارع هي القضيه العمر
نشوفه مشغولين بالتوافق زي ما يقولوا انا
انقل ما يقوله حريصين على متابعه اخبار
المغفلين وغيرهم انت شايفهم يعني فعاليه
فيها اي واحد من هؤلاء المشاهير بتلقاهم
بالالف
رصيد ومن الثقافه من العلم يكاد يكون بصفر
يعني بالتالي هذا الخوف من انه هذا الجيل
هو الذي مواجهات مستقبل مواجهه التحديات
هل
شايف انه الامر له خطوره ولا هذا مبالغ
يعني اكثر منه مبالغ جدا ارى ان الجيل هذا
من ناحيه المعلومات المهارات احسن من اللي
يعني هو مره يقولون باللغه الهيروغليفيه
قبل 4000 سنه عند الفراعنه لكن همم
مكتوب نص واحد 40 نكات ويقول انجيلها
يومين ما يحترم الكبار بس انا قبل 4000
سنه دائما يعني جزء من ثقافه البشر الاكبر
ما عندها تقييم ايجابي الافكار اللي كانت
موجوده الاسلام
غير قضيه المهاره غير قضيه التحاق بالعمل
اللي خارج التقرير فك تقييم اجمالي احنا
نرى تقدم في الجير في مهارات وفي معارفه
في ما يصنع من واقعه لكن عامل القلق اللي
هي شرط قبل قليل في قضيه ايضا هذا اللي هي
قضيه احترام
التعدد الثقافي همم يعني واحده من من اشعه
يعني واحده من عناوين المرحله ما بعد يعني
من الرؤيه هو التعدد الثقافي اللي احنا
نفاخر فيه واللي نبرزه واللي نعتقد انه
عامل جذب الثقافتنا باعتبار انه
احد المناش حق صحيح فبالتالي لازم الجيل
هذا ينشا على قضيه الاحترام والتعدد
الثقافي لانه باعتبار هذه احد يعني
مرتكزات هويه البلد والله فيها تفاصيل
كثيره كثيره
كذلك انها وضعت همم
الاصبع على الجرح وربما حتى وجه صيات
للبرامج تحفيزيه وتمويليه ايضا التوجيه
الناس اسابيع وفعاليات وتعليقات والى اخره
شاكر مقدمه
السلامه انا استمتع دائما بحضورك استلام
الوايل استاذ علم الاجتماع المشارك في
جامعه الملك سعود
تشريعات حديثه وحملات دوليه للتعريف بها
اهلا بكم سلسله من المبادرات والبرامج
اطلقتها السعوديه لتطوير القطاع السياحي
خلال العام الحالي اعتذ ذلك ضمن الجهود
المتسارعه للارتقاء بالقطاع ليحتل مركزا
متقدما على الصعيدين الاقليمي والعالمي
المتابعه في التقرير الثاني العام 2022
كان عاما استثنائيا لقطاع السياحه
السعوديه انظمه ومبادرات جديده ارقام
قياسيه من حيث نمو السياحي وعدد الغرف
الفندقيه الجديده وشركات عالميه تضع
القطاع على المسار الصحيح لتحقيق
مستهدفاته لعام 2030 نظام السياحه الجديد
والذي اقره مجلس الوزراء السعودي في اغسطس
كان الانجاز الابرز على صعيد البيئه
التنظيميه والتشريعيه للقطاع ويستند
النظام على افضل الممارسات في العالميه
بناء على مؤشر افضل عشر دول في القدره
التنفسيه للسياحه والسفر الصادر عن
المنتدى الاقتصاديه العالمي ومن ضمني ما
اشتمل عليه النظام اداره عمليه منح
التراخيص واطلاق تصاريح الانشطه السياحيه
التجريبيه وتقديم حزمه من الاجراءات
لاداره الازمات وتقديم الضمانات الماليه
لبعض الانشطه السياحيه اضافه الى انشاء
قاعده بيانات معلوماتيه تهدف الى توفير
البيانات والاحصاءات عن القطاع
2022 شهداء ايضا اطلاق برنامج رواد
السياحه الذي يهدف الى تنميه قدرات مئه
الف شاب وشابه سعوديين وتزويدهم بالمهارات
الرئيسيه في مجال الضيافه والسفر
ويستفيد المشاركون في البرنامج من منح
تدريبيه في ابرز المعاهد المحليه
والعالميه في دول تتضمن فرنسا وسويسرا
والمملكه المتحده
على صعيدي تعزيز صوره القطاع عالميا
استضافه الرياضه نسخه الاكبر من القمه
العالميه للمجلس العالمي للسفر والسياحه
والتي حضارها
5700 مشارك من بينهم 250 من الرؤساء
التنفيذيين لكبرى شركات الضيافه والسفر
عالميا
تعزيز الشركات الدوليه لقي دعم ايضا من
الهيئه السعوديه للسياحه التي روجت
للمملكه في المؤتمرات العالميه ومن بينها
سوق السفر العالمي في لندن الذي شهدت
توقيعه على 11 شراكه دوليه مع مؤسسات مثل
اجودا ولوفته ومع بدء بعض الكبرى المشاريع
السعوديه باستقبال الاولى الزوار في 2023
ستكون الاجنده السياحيه للسعوديه حافله
بالانجازات في العام الجديد
بدا اليوم برنامج الرياضه الخضراء عماله
تنفيذ تشجير الاحياء السكنيه بدايه من حي
العزيزيه الذي سيشهد زراعه 623 الف شجره
وشجيرا فضلا عن تشجيري اخذ 66 مدرسه و78
موقعا لمواقف السيارات واكثر من 170 كم من
الطرق يستهدف البرنامج اكثر من 120 حيا
سكنيا تشمل تنفيذ حدائق وتشجير الشوارع
الداخليه وتنفيذ ارصفه مشجره وغيرها
رياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد الواحد
الحميد عبد الواحد حياك الله
اذن هناك الان البدايه الفعليه ربما في
للتشجير امم في بعض المناطق في الرياض ما
هي التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بك خالد نعم نحن الان في حي
العزيزيه حيث
ينتصف هذا الحي حديقه كبيره من المقرر
انشاؤها وبدات بالفعل طبعا فيما يتعلق
بهذا الحديقه بدات بالفعل عمليات انشاء
الحديقه من ناحيه ممرات وكذلك من ناحيه
الزراعه حتى في منتصف هذه الحديقه نجد هذا
المعرض الذي يشرح للسكان همم ماذا سوف
يحتوي مشروع رياض الخضراء وتحديدا الخطه
المقرر البدء بها في فيما يتعلق بحي
العزيزيه نتحدث اكثر عن طبعا كل هذه
التفاصيل من خلال ال- ال- المعلومات
الظاهره في هذا المعرض هناك همم يعني همم
المعلومات التي يستقبل بها العارضون
السكان
ليشرحون لهم ماذا سوف يتم العمل عليه في
حي العزيزيه هذا المعرض يستمر حتى سبعه
يناير طبعا واليوم هو اول يوم نتحدث عن
اكثر من همم 176 كيلو متر من الطرق
والممرات اضافه الى ان انواع الاشجار
والشجيرات التي تم اختيارها طبعا تتم
زراعتها السوائل في العزيزيه او في احياء
الرياض ال120 هذه الاشجار والشجيرات يعني
تبتسم بانها لا تحتاج الكثير من الماء
ومناسبه كثيرا للبيئه المحليه خالد سالنا
المسؤولين في رياض الخضراء لماذا اختاروا
حي العزيزيه لاقامه هذا المعرض فاجابونا
بان حي العزيزيه اولا يكتظ بالسكان هذه
همم نقطه والنقطه الاخرى ان حي العزيزيه
كذلك في العديد من المصانع بالتالي من
اكثر الاحياء احتياجا
للزراعه الاشجار والشجيرات همم يعني همم
كنا قد سالنا كم عدد الحدائق
المقرر زراعتها هنا في حي العزيزيه
وانشاها بشكل يعني
متوزع في هذا الحي نتحدث عن اكثر من 50
حديقه نتحدث كذلك عن طبعا كل المرافق
الاخرى التي يتم العمل على تشجيرها من من
خلال البدء بهذا المشروع همم يعني نشاهد
في في الاسفل هذه هي الخريطه التي يتم من
خلالها الشرح هي السكان حول الاماكن التي
سوف يتم الزراعه بها حي العزيزيه خالد
يحتوي يعني اليوم يحتوي 10,000 شجره
تقريبا همم من مقرر ان تصل الى اكثر من
600,000 همم شجره وشجيره همم يعني هذه
الخطه المستقبليه فيما يتعلق بحي العزيزيه
حتى الان المعرض يستقبل السكان المحليين
من مختلف الاطياف هنا في حي العزيزيه همم
يشرح لهم هذه الخطه
ماذا سوف يتم العمل عليه في هذا الحي شكرا
لكم عبد الواحد يعطيك العافيه
ونبقى في الرياض التي شهدت ايضا افتتاح 17
حديقه توزعت في 13 حيا في مختلف احياء
العاصمه بمساحه
194.000 متر مربع هذه المبادره تهدف الى
زياده انتشار الحدائق داخل احياء العاصمه
ورفع مستوى جوده الحياه وتحسين المشاهد
الحضاريه وتطوير البنا التحتيه والفراغ
العام ايضا وذلك التماشيا مع المبادره
الرياض الخضراء التي تبلغ مساحتها في
الحدائق المطلقه 66.000 متر مربع
مهنه صيد الاسماك من اقدم واعرق المهن في
سلطنه عمان
الحكوميه الى ان السلطنه تضم اكثر من
49000 صيد جميل عبد الرحمن العصيمي في
ختامه سلسله تقارير العربيه في السلطنه
رافق احد هؤلاء الصياد في رحلته اليوميه
في ولايه صور متابعه
[موسيقى]
الساعه تشير الى السادسه صباحا خيوط الشمس
تداعب شواطئ راس الحد فايل الحربي يستعد
لخوض عباد البحر مبكرا
منذ نشاته لا يعرف سوى صيد الاسماك كمصدر
دخل الله
من اهلنا يعني اهالينا قبل يعني عايشين من
البحر
الا هي الصيد
[موسيقى]
يعني اشتغلت بديت اول ما بديت عمري عشر
سنوات
ضليت اطلع مع والدي اطلع مع اخواني ونتعلم
معاهم درجه درجه
هذا المكان يشهدوا اول شروق الشمس في
الشرق الاوسط فهو يقع بين ثلاثه مواقع
بحريه بحري عمان وبحر العرب والمحيط
الهندي
[موسيقى]
يبدو متفائلا هذا الصباح الدلافين ترافق
قريبه الصغير الطعم هو الاخر جاهزا
لاستقبال الاسماك الحظ بدا يبتسم لهذا
الصياد الثلاثيني بعد صبري عده ساعات في
عرض البحر
[موسيقى]
يعني شيء كبير جدا
مهنه الصيد مهنا مهنا حلوه جدا
وصح ان هي متعبه متعبه تطلع ما تعرف عمرك
ما ترجع او ما بترجع يعني صعب وايد فيها
صعب
اكثر من تسعه واربعين الف صياد عماني في
السلطنه بحسب الارقام الحكوميه بالاضافه
الى وجود اسطول كبير للصيد حيث يبلغ عدد
سفن وقوارب الصيد اكثر من 14,000 و900
سفينه واستدع من حكومي مستمر لهذا القطاع
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من ولايه السور
العربيه
يسمى شهر يناير في العراق وبلاد الشام
كانون الثاني وهي لفظه عربيه ماخوذه من
كنا او كنا تفاصيل في تقويم مع خالد
الزعبي
[موسيقى]
شهر يناير هو الشهر الاول من شهور السنه
الميلاديه واحد سبعه شهور الذي يتكون من
31 يوما يسمى بالعراق وبلاد الشام كانون
ثاني وهي لفوه عربيه ماخوذه من كنا ايستقر
في مكانه من شده البرد ويناير ماخوذه من
اللفظه اللاتينيه
والتي تعني البوابه في يناير بوابه الدخول
الى السنه وما داخله الاشياء لها عند
الشعوب القديمه ومدخل سنه تسمى بجانوس عند
الرومان ولهذا يطلق البعض بجانوري وفيه
تحل الارواح الجديده على الارض وقاتل جسمي
مقتول بفعلته وقاتل الروح لا تدري به
البشر
[موسيقى]
ففي اول الشهر تكون الشمس في اقرب نقطه
لها من الارض بما يسمى بالحضيض الارض وفي
منتصفه موسم شباط وهو موسم الرياح الماكره
التي لا تستقر على جهه معينه واشباط مقطع
ارباط وفي نهايته الاستعداد لموسم بذره
الست وهي سته ايام صالحه لزراعه جميع
المحاصيل شتويه كانت ام صيفيه ثلاثه ايام
من اخر الشبط وثلاثه ايام من اول العقارب
ثلاثه ايام هي الدهر كله وما هن غير الامس
واليوم والغذي وما البدر الا واحد غير انه
يغيب وياتي بالضياء
المجددي
[موسيقى]
الختام بالعنايه
تطورات جديده
مع الثقافه السعوديه مقارنه بالاجال
السابقه
برنامج مبادره الرياض الخضراء انطلاق رحله
التشجير 120 حيه
رابعه توثيق الرحله اليوميه للصيادين
الاسماك في سلطنه عمان
[موسيقى]